and she was hot i don't think guys it's
funny because the red pill is so big on
like age but i found it's more about
people just get fat when they're older
like if you stay in shape guys don't
seem to care as much if you're
attractive it doesn't matter how old you
are yeah yeah i do i feel like this
whole like oh she's past 30 she's not
attractive i feel like that's matt
that's massive cap man like
if an attractive if a footballer's wife
he was in her 40s
and they're all like glammed up they're
all hot like you wouldn't say no like
you would choose a her over the average
22 year old like you're kidding yourself
tom brady's wife giselle whatever i
don't know what she looks like what she
look like is she hot so yeah show me oh
there's a bit too many there's a bit too
many absolutes in the red pool i think
something as a general some things are
kind of true but this girl
oh she's wow she's insane yeah she was
voted like most beautiful woman in the
world
i was still
oh
i would still take megan good over her
but yeah really yeah i don't think megan
gets that attractive she's gorgeous she
got this she got she got the curves she
got there is it the body or the face
everything she has
amazing eyes amazing yes guys let me
know in the chat amazing body do you
think megan good is that hot
she's so hot man
i think she's just laughing like you
know like margot robbie you're like oh
do you know why i'm not crazy about
margot robbie
this sounds so
sounds so harsh
she's aesthetically very beautiful
and i'll be honest i'll be honest
nowadays
i'll take a booty
i like a booty and she ain't got it
that's i've heard that you know what's
weird i remember in like seventh grade
when all of a sudden ass was like a
thing or not seventh grade like
i don't know i said seventh grade like
16 17. it was like there was a switch in
the culture from like this the skinny
girls yeah and then all of a sudden that
ass song came out and it's like ass ass
that was a culture that was a cultural
icon because that that's kim kim k
facilitated that switch
practically
she facilitated that
she really did the she she was the
poster okay i think her ass
is that good
because in my opinion it looks nice a
diaper
yeah yeah it's
it's too much i like i like real [ __ ]
i like it real
and so it's it's like it's like oh it
would make you look
but then i feel like
now i'll take a real one
day actually i was gonna ask you that so
it makes a difference to a guy if it's
like fake or real well i've never felt a
fake bomb before what about fake boobs i
have yeah it feels nice i'll be honest
it doesn't matter i would i would i
would rather
i would rather small real boobs
than fake big ones really yeah that's so
easy
and
some small blues can be fun to play with
like that's so interesting and they're
just nicer to feel
boobs real boobs in general are just
nicer to feel that's so interesting
because
like i feel like girls will spend so
much money getting this [ __ ] for guys
and when i talk to guys like
they don't even seem to like that stuff
or even like the heavy makeup and stuff
like the more i talk to guys the more
like my brother always tells me oh i
like that girl but she wears too much
makeup
yeah that's true it's interesting
because like the girls are doing it
because they think that's what the guy
wants
yeah but no they're doing it because
it's what girls want
girls dress for girls i don't
no they don't that's what they do
you don't think that's true i don't
think that's true do you really think a
guy is going to notice what kind of
makeup you use
no but i think when they have their like
a low-cut top they're not doing it so
the girls love
no i'm not saying they just okay there
are some things that obviously you're
going to do for male attention
that's true it's not one or the other
but
the fine tuning of things
i think because guys we don't notice
that [ __ ]
yeah but sometimes guys think they like
the no makeup look
but yeah no you guys they like it with
an attractive girl
no they like the light makeup look
that's a guy yeah that's perfect but
you accentuate what you already have
yeah yeah that's perfect but not the
heavy but i'm not i'm not good at makeup
that's not i don't really wear much
because that's why they love you it's
like because they know what they're
getting
because it's only happened a couple of
times
where i've
kind of maybe gone home with a girl she
had a full face on oh no and then
in the morning i was like oh are you
doing different
yeah this was like
i started drinking and [ __ ] i don't
really drink that much now but i was
like i mean i'm drinking a coffee so
well i was like if because if you're
sober you you had because you can just
see it on people's faces the cake
i think
i think that just comes with experience
i'll be honest
oh really yeah
i think that comes with experience
a man will date an older woman but he
will reconsider things when it comes to
marriage 100
older women is like for fun and
experience
how interesting how what's the oldest
you would date i would date no you would
marry so oh i would marry i know you
don't really want to get married but i'm
on the fence okay but if you did get
married what's the oldest you would go
you're 28 i'm 28. okay
you're right in the female epiphany
phase
starting to hit my price
it started to hit my price
have you noticed a difference in dating
from when you're 22 to now [ __ ] like is
it uh is it night and day
not so much because
if i'm being completely honest like in
my adult life i've never really had a
problem getting
getting women
but now it's
i'll be on compared to i was like 21 22
it's a lot easier
do you have girls because you're you're
like like before they wouldn't they
wouldn't approach me they would like
send me signals
that maybe they're interested
i'm not saying i'm not trying to get
every single girl but like now i feel
like more girl i get more signals from
more girls and it's got to a point now
even a few girls will actually make the
first move what are your dms like are
they crazy
no they're not girls are really not you
guys don't really dm me really yeah i
think only every now and again but oh
okay i figured because you're an actor
cause you're like you're pretty big in
london right uh i'm not big
in my industry i'm known i'd say i'm
more like like people
know because they've seen my stuff for
like you know i'm getting cast for stuff
and i'm working with like big people
which is great
so
i'm not like commercially known
like being successful in theater
specifically
doesn't always
mean like like anyone who goes to if
they're if someone's like a theater fan
then they probably would have seen me
before
and they become like they might follow
all my stuff
but it's not like like if you don't go
to the theater then you just wouldn't
know have you ever dated anyone famous
uh
yeah
like she's like a reality tv famous
tell me i need to know
okay you probably don't know her
i can tell you what show she was on what
was show love island
she won one year
that was one year she won
she won her year so then isn't she
supposed to be in love if she won
it didn't last long
because i kind of had a thing after she
came out so oh really yeah and she's in
oh i'm not going to say that
no tell me show me show me i won't tell
them you always say i won't show them
okay i'll show you